well the ending of last episode sucked
really tough no it was good no I liked
it
there's a bunch of dead dogs here now
dog said screw your outro my gosh Oh a
blue plant hold on don't
what's your inventory look I'm like
right now don't take that
I got this sick crank yo
the kids are doing these days oh that
looks like where I was just at wait I
understand this space let me look at a
map I'm sorry I like don't understand
where I am so I got two doors one is red
and locked and then the one behind me I
should be able to go in maybe mm-hmm
facing north northeast so doesn't matter
I was just trying to help
well you didn't Wow you you've
accomplished so much by going up and
down the stairs I'm observing the space
it looks like a fountain but there's no
water coming out it needs a crank you're
so sure of it ratchet and crank all
right it's right I mean I'm looking for
a square in just looking for a square
and
can I fall in there yeah I just jumped
out no no jump down again what if I did
died that'd be awesome yeah you haven't
saved in a while you should be pretty
like tense right now
Jesus I'm not worried but I'm not the
one playing my embarrassments not on the
line my prized online things it harder
oh no no I don't like that come on in
the water's pan no way there's like
zombie fish in there there's a square
shaped hole oh I know it sounds like the
new Radiohead album square shaped hole
shaped pole Hughes
I'll drain that [ __ ] manually see a
sucker
what kind of psycho designed this
swimming pool with that giant grate down
there I do not want to swim in that
I'm fine I'm fine
wait there's the water in there well I
need a side the walkway yeah I don't
like that squish squash squish squash
split plot run nice
thank you for well executed thank you
well the clip what's over here like what
am i doing i the moths flocked the light
I started writing this is no no our
voice mouth walked into my office legs
up to here got two bullets in me have
you ever smelled mothballs one of them's
a shot of whiskey I have yeah how do you
get their little legs apart the moths
how this is joke how do you get my
little legs apart oh okay sorry I'm
tired I get it mothballs ha ha all right
I don't think it's crows in a second
that could be wrong I hope I'm wrong and
that you run attacks you this looks
gross a joke yeah this where it was No
no no it just looks similar doesn't it
there's a waterfall on this one there's
a door over here how many bullets do I
have left and mic thingy - alright I
just want to keep that in mind
sure look at any of this stuff like
maybe there's a secret here a raging
waterfall oh no it was raging she's got
it closed Dixon it's a raging what if uh
it looks like there's something beyond
it
there's always something behind if you
are playing a game and you don't check
behind the waterfall that's on you
you've never played a video game before
in fact if you're in real life and you
don't check behind waterfalls you don't
know what kind of [ __ ] could be hiding
behind there take a page out of our
friend Laura's book oh I do not like
that that's a [ __ ] angle alright so it's
a zig zag aroo into a mystery box love
it here we go
Oh with a red plant oh my god
there's gonna be a dog in here I just
know it
are you tapping on the mic that's no
sorry Mary yes I was I didn't meet you
though there's holes holes you got to go
dig those homes that's the last one I
promise don't don't just run there
snakes she lied to me I don't like
snakes though it's creeping out more
than yawn did the big one I'd rather it
be normal-sized that's slithering around
down there Draco Malfoy is God can I get
poisoned like the other time when I
needed to see Maebh what's that they
look like hands like roots root
vegetable of some sort curb spice
all right I'm in a house for yay more
plants I feel like I should be taking
these your inventory is pretty full
right I know wait do you hear that can
you turn up the volume
Jesus [ __ ] you can't set me up like set
yourself up I hear breathing it's
probably you mouth breather going in you
just startled - is it - easily I'm
playing a scary game yes does it have a
box has a box has a cantina thingies
oh I'm saving it's been like on before
you say they'll just collect the stuff
from around the room and put in the box
you have to do that after you save yeah
okay that's smart
what other you mean like the plants or
you mean the stuff in this room like you
get the plants that stuff and the plants
you want those blue pants eventually in
say a box you want those pants yep I'm
full so I'm gonna keep this shotgun and
try to get rid of it I'm gonna keep this
I I don't want you don't need to Craig
but then I'm gonna save this go get
those blue plants first night save yeah
wait I think I saw something on the end
of the at the end of the room to ink
ribbons I think I saw something shiny
there first day it's great on the floor
- gosh all these plants damn right I
don't think I remember what the blue
plants do I know that if you combine a
red and a green it saves two slots or
mean it it it fills two Health slots
mm-hmm but I don't think I know what a
blue and a red and a blue and a green do
does it have to do with um there's a
note you can look back at later but was
it a bow stocked on health and
everything was it about like if you get
sick or something should I combine them
okay no I'll just leave them for now
I wouldn't combine things so you know
what you need okay I'm doing well all
right so do I need anything else I got
two guns if feel pretty good about that
with a lot of ammo I got a spray now I
find this interesting it gave me a fuel
canteen it gave me stuff to replenish my
fuel which to me means there's gonna be
zombozo's in here so this is what I'm
thinking
okay does that make sense make sense
oh wait there's still something out on
there and we'll take that rebound and I
will save right now nice it is nice it's
my favorite part of the game record your
findings oh no almost Oh over wrote the
wrong one even saving stressful yeah it
shouldn't be but you're making it the
blood splatters don't help no Dexter
they know it once better specialist BSS
alright stop yes AAA you've had an eye
out here we go so I am going to go off
into the world yeah a little bit older a
little bit wiser super alive uh too wise
as expected zeros double oh one getting
to see patterns okay there's two doors
one ahead and one to the right I'm gonna
go to this one that one has a hole near
it
those handles abate animal horns let me
think about all right let me try these
other doors because one yeah someone
with the hole we're so close to it yeah
that was so satisfying I was I was
really excited that to happen just so
you know there are many dangers in this
house that you didn't you weren't ready
for doesn't seem to be anything useful
well [ __ ] you what's that noise
oh it's the Massa man this camera angle
sucks where is that tentacle mm I must
but I must still her
why won't they write about me no they
probably did special tactics and Rescue
Squad there's the door to the right and
it's locked and then there's door at the
end of the hallway gallery
a map oh definitely
okay so now I have a better map mm-hmm
I'll go into this non spider door Oh No
what if there's a zombie in the shower
on the other side no oh my god those
things are huge
but it's not necessary to destroy stars
what about my family
[ __ ] almost died two bees
alright so should I go on that door or
don't think you can things lost now
that's the blue or gray or whatever hey
you kid going probably double double -
sorry
double zero - its double Oh - that won't
you
have you ever seen Jill those movies
about that Harry I heard someone talking
oh it's [ __ ] cool I think you just
starting to take its toll talking to
myself is becoming up bad you wire that
guy's a liar yourself you all right
what's gotten into you girls blank dumps
there I'm getting you're worried aren't
I yeah I'm all right
there's giant creepy mansion has gotten
to my nerves
I'll go outside get some fresh air for a
change
okay Shay Diaz balls yeah yeah
don't worry I'm just gonna get some
fresh air you just said that I'm lucky
I'll get to wait some monsters along the
way are you gonna warn him about the
spider
hopefully it doesn't go in that room
nice that guy's definitely hide in some
[ __ ] how do you know they vomited blood
on the dissenter maybe they just got
stuck I mean it could just be blood from
anything yeah the fact that you know how
it came out is weird Jill Valentine the
world's greatest detective oh did I do
the wrong way she's like kicking the
letter as she goes she's got a metal
interview
stop no she talks she's smart this
fountain seems to not have water how she
talks if I don't need that crazy just
sick oh I can move this box did you see
that yeah you're trying to push it in
the wall though there's a bunch of boxes
okay into the water they go it's a
really blue water city I'm plans as
weekend this is gonna take a while I'm
just asking because it's gonna be boring
oh right cuz you don't actually care
about would have anything for the
weekend no uh yeah I think I'm Ashley
aren't you having a party
oh [ __ ] yeah probably know that it's not
mine it's my roommates yeah I think I
might go over but um pretty cool and I
was invited doing another party oh I'm
gonna go to one during the day and then
go to yours I'm going I'm going to uh
the other one as well are you well that
works out well
mm-hmm you want to go together no
laughing I'm not really gonna I don't
know anything about it giant sucker in
an invite to your for yourself yeah so I
know where it is I could show up and
crash it I'm not sure what I'm doing I'm
just kind of
those two should have been enough close
to the box gets to the water the less
I'm caring I'm just kidding I'm kidding
I hope you find the party a little bit
fun of my party as well
everyone's gonna judge it wrong nice
nimble footwork if I might if I don't if
I do say so myself
quiet I'd like to take that considering
I was almost killed by bees I'm gonna
take it go for it
really what she didn't bring the lighter
in the fluid he'll be fine no I don't
like it yeah that's a sick shot though
check it out
ambien is I don't like it so my
controller is vibrating when I get in
the water
I'm gonna have someone hide in this
stream room before one of the episodes
no I mean no I want to leave oh ha okay
no I don't like it I think I'm gonna die
in here yeah I don't so I got around the
corner and go into the pokeball to get
into that inner area
no no no no what is it [ __ ] shark
you're good zombies oh my god orchestra
kicked in we're gonna need bigger boat
sharks they plan every fear imaginable
don't don't use shotgun shells alright
so I don't want to tell you you have to
go back upstairs you'd probably be
better off dying is it save time you
saved upstairs already
what is that
I can't kill this it's not hurting you
control system for the water tank it's
completely but it attacked me before
you're accomplishing a lot right now
though shut up what am i doing
just go back upstairs you might you
honestly you might could just die it's
not that big of it well I might yeah you
might get Richard Dreyfuss he died in
Jaws Oh God there are these little
safety nooks these are nice they can't
get me up here right you know this is
what is this okay power room the words
power room is written on the door s poor
grammar come on Capcom oh I see it oh he
sees you oh he sees you oh he saw you
oh he's hungry I don't know a dog sure
no dodging sharks that one is bigger
than the others you're honestly better
off having died there and you wasted an
herb sorry it's hit the mic
ah no I don't die on purpose
ooh someone's someone's mr. fiver
someone's clean streak of not doing too
shitty God ended on this episode that's
it innit
I'm just kidding you're doing fine
you're just holding your kidney because
it's the noise is coming from her hands
the twist
she robot hands you should have died uh
at least use your pistol oh my god
Rajyam use the dagger and then dodging I
thought you want me to get rid of my
shotgun well when and when it's useful
I didn't mean unload shells into a plan
I can't I can't
nice getting better at it way there's a
bathroom to your right go there what's
really yes nice I don't have to pee man
things are not going well
dude bugs all over the floor what key P
set it yeah I examine the key when you
can bet he fight the zombie was [ __ ]
when you walked in taking a fat close
the door
taking a thick dump all right this place
is not inviting if I die to B's I'm so
mad oh sweet can I kill that spider
oh that spider does this attack me again
how didn't I kill you I thought your
unread why'd you go back through life
isn't panic move you oh I should be dead
yeah you should be dead I should be dead
your dark red alright so I'm supposed to
like climb up on here or something
wait what's your inventory looking like
I'm gonna go to a safe box okay alright
you're gonna die
you can't give back without I can't go
through no it's dumb she's there's a
hole under there that you good I got a
cover-up I can't do it from this side
correct you can't do it I'm gonna die
yeah you got [ __ ] over just sprint
over though you might as well try to
sprint over the hole I can't sprint I
mean like just running don't look back
what I thought you what the [ __ ] I was
come on god damn it crimson she's
hurting yes she's in deep [ __ ] mm-hmm
wait wait okay on before I go the Savior
I'm just unlock the door behind you just
to get rid of the key that was the zero
zero one key zero zero one zero zero one
alright I'm not gonna go into that I'm
try so hard to get you killed before the
end of this episode I have like 10
minutes no you don't you the rest of
your life okay oh my god those freaking
all right so I'm gonna heal and then I'm
gonna save that way I'm ready to go
mm-hmm save I wouldn't save you really
wouldn't even lose that much progress if
you if I do get you do if you do die
yeah all right well should I just use
three green herbs or should I should now
should use this right yeah I need three
things
don't I get rid of your lighter fluid
and stuff I mean meet three three what
what protects against sharks the best
nothing you're not going down there yet
I need to heal so bad
fine all right cool all right cool
man what I don't know kind of
disappointed you why cuz I lived I'm the
greatest don't you alright I see it Oh
something swaying in the wind I did I
see that
I bet he's alive he liked being slept in
Oh what what other kind of gun is there
little pew pew yeah right I had to do it
we ran from those things helping each
other to survive but Robert started to
show the symptoms I had to do it those
damn things are pure evil there was no
other way he would have done the same if
it were the other way around after I put
him out of his misery I had to leave him
in the bathroom now I'm probably the
last one how could this happen I'll
never forgive myself for being part of
this project eventually I'll get what's
coming to me though there's no way to
escape from this nuthouse it's just a
matter of time now everything is set all
I need a little courage to get it done
knowing that I'll leave many things
undone is regret beyond words but this
is better than waiting to turn into one
of them please understand and at least
let me end my life as a person there is
a message on the back Linda please
forgive me I met your wife she's [ __ ]
grass that wasn't that was Lisa whatever
it's hard to there handgun rounds
everywhere
okay this room is done this room is
clean it's got a bathroom to hate
bathrooms oh wait there's a dude in
there he told me no that was the other
guy yeah all right so just right and
that's on my right [ __ ] this place is so
confusing all right so it's like this oh
he did in this bathroom
what the [ __ ] was that
well it worked out the first time
remember you got a dagger out of it
okay get it nice yeah there you go run
away I bet you like I fell oh no he's
he's still hanging you're fine you're
dumb you're dumb and a liar and I hate
it
screams green wait no now we don't know
who's right though go back and check no
please I know it's right I know no
there's no way you have to prove it fine
okay okay okay I understand
so I have to push this box in there
mm-hmm okay I got it
do I push it on top of the hole put your
next the other box and then I just go up
and down and then up again your and then
up and them down again
mm-hmm stop do the thing really you're
in this close
two pages I have really hope you got it
passed at that time
upsy-daisy
so the control room key was that safety
area in the shark jack second you should
save things could go awry
just in case I feel like that's very
foreboding well for my situation mm-hmm
in the interest of time you could save
the save room again the one right next
to you that's right here to your right
it's to hurt yet hung get out that one
to your right yeah to yours and hers to
yours and her top right okay good all
right I'm just gonna quickly save then
we can go until I don't feel safe
anymore or I die
mm-hmm
no saving my progress I'm gonna live so
this is just a nice thing to do I'm not
gonna die
oh wait do I need this safety gun no cuz
the only got one bullets taking up a
whole slot it's like a one-hit kill but
it's kind of like yeah don't even worry
about it
how about the square crank no that guy
was pretty good here we go
slow gonna use the control key swim with
sharks oh my god those sharks were huge
they were so big they were pretty large
what do they been eating like how
they've been staying alive humans and
zombies and other sharks sharks eat
other sharks giant one was pretty big
that's just the food chain is there
somebody in here caramel mer
ah Jesus
forgot about them - you're so fleetwood
Fleetfoot max stop that's not a thing
people say nobody's ever sick dodging
though fleet Mack Dodge Caravan status
right are they known for their dodge oh
they aren't that door let me look at
your inventory okay cool
I got it I got a I got a little guy if
you fall in there what happens okay just
can't okay it would bar your entrance I
cannot dodge no or fight these sharks Oh
No can I be smart about God and you just
run fast enough yeah if you keep going
like you can you can serpentine if you
want but you should be fine like they're
both after me okay they got me I don't
understand how dog sharks
we're almost there oh you're almost
there oh he's got oh man you seized you
left yeah nice sweet you made it
probably on yellow I would soon yeah I
would assume that Chicka Chicka Chicka
look at them they're so big I can't gets
me dying let's go taunting sharks it's
gonna be funny when they they will not
this is where I will make friends with
them
yikes
whoa
ah that's scary
oh my god
sorry higher air roar I'm just not ready
yet
mmm I wouldn't pick that up oh I can
still say now
what fresh hell is this I don't want to
open this I don't think it's gonna let
you there's water on their side I wish
like a shark came out of nowhere just
bashed up against a classroom or it like
had me open the door and then just in
the tank with the sharks getting eaten
mm-hmm well read that marker board sorry
it's hard to caution in case of a drop
in oil pressure open valve number one
where's the valves these which one says
valve number one God all right this is
gonna kill me here we go wait which is
the one
it's these mm-hmm
tips
it's simple just just drain the water
you got it how did he know what I was
doing start pressing switches hurry up
there's other switches what switches in
the room the other computers drop that
go release the safety where's this
puzzles really stupid it's just like a
timer that's making you where's
activate okay okay okay that's the oil
one so I know the oil one oh no oh my
god what are you doing
I hit one I'm kidding geez now do you do
the thing again oh my god [ __ ] you
but if that door didn't close then I'd
be mad and probably dead drain that [ __ ]
all right kill that [ __ ] I hope you
like oxygen I think they do and I think
that you're thinking of whales that's a
shark I can't hear you
are you dead wait go to that door nope
oh right go back down sir I mean you
can't now it scoop scan scan scan scan
scan scan Oh aren't they gonna be on the
ground though like this Liberty flopping
er yeah it's gonna be satisfying as [ __ ]
to watch can't take this now sure
do I need it sure now have a free slot
Wow Kika popping scare oh right that
well forgot yes oil operated hinges in
1972
this is 96 what noise is gonna make I
was way off low so I like your creaky
one thank you
oh I don't like this area those gates
sound terrible
some Python rounds what's up Mac oh
that's for my Magnum gun that makes
sense
so I want to go up you can come back
down
particularly you wanna come back
well if I can't okay you're right
got me unlock it unlock it oh it's the
shortcut but it's red
well because it's live from the other
side oh it's lock from this side so you
can unlock it now you might as well then
you come back down here I understand I'm
never coming down here again yeah you
are no I'm not all right all right so
now okay is that a harp Jill but no the
music not what I'm seeing how am I
supposed to know what you're describing
right now they have wd-40 these much to
your chagrin there's acid shells in the
ground there red granite a grenade
launcher rounds I take them mm-hmm
Syria's green mm-hmm what about this
door
sure is this the shark doors mm-hmm
ah guys so not dead I knew it I can't
get over there yeah you can oh my god
they're even scary when they're dying
mm-hmm
wait that one's still in water no I
don't want to go in there no that one's
alive so finish him how she's too
cautious
no he's alive get up get up get up get
up
sure this looks super dangerous it sure
does
probably turn it off the shark is in
water right mm-hmm but I've
there's a key there that I need he's
gonna eat me now go back out there no
not up the here back we were if I turn
it on
do I have an item no I check that thing
first oh there is a little shinier
mama all right
almost
I don't understand I can't do anything
now I can't leave he's facing me I know
don't turn that on if you turn it on
electricity's gonna pour out of it right
so use that to your advantage so I do
want to turn no it's not yet it's
actually kind of like weird looking
because it's you can't tell it's not an
item I don't have an ID all right just
to save time you can't tell but when he
he just broke the bar so you could push
that machine into the water now there we
go it's not the best camera angle
sian hope you like thirty thousand three
hundred sixty volts your face wait oh
wait you good shouldn't have killed me
no that's why the thing short-circuited
okay get that key son um gallery
I remember where that is nope I might
have to save now before the gallery yeah
[ __ ] yeah where's the other one though
there's my brother what if the shark
comes back at the end for revenge
he's like learned how to breathe
underwater or out of water has it where
thanks going you know Dumbledore
Dumbledore yeah
he's amazed mm-hmm oh my god I'm tired
my jokes are shitty they're they're
pretty bad later in the day than we
usually record don't ya know I've been
gone for like two weeks
I don't even think you're tired I just
think you're you're self-aware more than
ever of how bad your jokes maybe that's
it maybe wait I don't ever know yeah I
go through there okay
can I only go through this door three
times that kind of had a creak to it at
the end all right where am I okay nope
all right like how quickly you catch
that I have no idea what you're actually
amazing I don't see me funny when you'll
have your hands and get throwing that
zombie comes at you oh yeah there's aa B
come here dumb dumb I wish this is kind
of like time-consuming it's gonna be
flesh consuming in a second crap dagger
oh now you have to kill him go back you
might as well he'll be back through here
well back up back up blood I think he
would have gotten up buying it our butts
shoot him why not shoot him why you're
not shooting him just try to look cool
there I'm calm
it's cool he might not be dead there I
see blood
I can't burn in all right
is this the bees yes [ __ ] I wish I could
shoot the bees these a lot of the bees
be dodge Dodge Stratus I remember you
please don't walk over that hole mm-hmm
give me some credit walk the wrong way
off the box sweet so no yeah okay save
room city come on
I'd like all these things my ribbons am
I out of ribbons you have one other one
but you okay I got two out of three I'm
fine
you'll also find soon she's that's weak
really stressful how much they don't
mm-hmm sweet you made some progress you
almost died unfortunately you did not
should I go into that place real fast
you know probably episode I have to go I
don't want to keep your date waiting
it's not a date
I have a date with a buddy where you
going I'm not the end of the episode I
was gonna try to trick you and go to
that room real fast no I have to go I
don't know how else to tell you
okay a next episode on the with the
conclusion are you gonna give him a
keeping a little taste the spider yeah I
want to know what it's like wait what
that's what this room looks like it's
huge cute a huge oh [ __ ] him up is he
gonna find me no he's not here pincers
are getting sweaty funny I am smelling
bacon smell your crispy skin oh he's
like so fluffy so crispy there goes one
of his legs [ __ ] you
what that was it all right sweet preview
of next episode he's gonna be back next
episode oh you're right yeah okay I'm
not gonna say cool thank you guys for
joining us do not forget to Like and
subscribe so you can keep doing this
awesome stuff thanks for hanging out and
I will see you guys on the next episode
of Resident knievel evil knievel
resident can evil don't see you guys you
guys I thought what it's called
that's called